welcome to the Stanford Graduate School
of Business is knight Management Center
the knight Management Center unites the
facilities of the Stanford Graduate
School of Business into a vibrant indoor
and outdoor living and learning
community there are eight buildings with
360 thousand square feet and a half of
the 12.5 acres site is preserved for
open space located across the street
from the school's Schwab residential
center the knight Management Center
gives students faculty and staff the
sense of being in a small village but
one that remains connected to the
broader Stanford campus all the
classrooms in the academic buildings are
located on the ground floor these large
spaces showcase the learning activities
inside there are also smaller study in
seminar rooms to fit a variety of
academic needs there is a variety of
artwork at night from the cornerstone
that welcomes entrance from the Stanford
community to the artwork that modified
the verb to change apropos for a school
whose motto is change lives change
organizations change the world